[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشهري
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه
نبدا من كيف هذه الجوله حيث اعلنت السلطات
الاوكرانيه رغبتها في انعقاد قمه للسلام
تنهي حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا التي دخلت
قبل ايام شهرها الحادي عشر
ومن رام الله نتابع هذه الصور وذلك في ظلي
توتر عنيف سببه الرئيسي رفض قوات الاحتلال
تسليما جثامين شهداء للجانب الفلسطيني
ومن يورك طبعا هذه المشاهد مع ارتفاع
الخسائر البشريه والماديه الناجمه عن
عاصفه ثلجيه تعتبر الاخطر منذ عقود في
الولايات المتحده
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
ردا على قرار مجموعه السبع الصناعيه
والاتحاد الاوروبي بوتن يحضر توريد نفطر
سي ومشتقاته الى الدول التي تفرض سقفا
لاسعاره والمرسوم يدخل حيز التنفيذ بدايه
فبراير المقبل
سيجال بينكاب وموسكو بشان قمه سلام
مقترحها روسيا تبدي استعدادها لبحث ما
تسميها القضايا الاستراتيجيه الكبرى اذا
غيرت الاداره الامريكيه نهجها اوكرانيا
تريد قمه بواسطه اماميه والمنظمه الدوليه
تشترط موافقه جميع الاطراف
جاتا مينو الشهداء مصدر تصعيد جديد بين
الفلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
الشرطه الاسرائيليه تطلق النار والغازات
المسيله للدموع على متظاهرين قرب معبر
قلنديا وبلده سلوان عنوان توترا فجرته
محاوله مستوطنين الاستيلاء على قطعه ارض
شمل القدس
حواجز للسرب على الطرق الرئيسيه تؤجج
المخاوف من موجه عنف جديده في كوسوفو وغدا
تواضع قوته في حاله استغفار الرئيس
الصربيه يتهم الغرب والبانه
وفي لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اعلان اوكرانيا انها تسعى
لعقد قمه للسلام مع روسيا بحلول نهايه
فبراير المقبل وانها تفضل ان تكون في
الامم المتحده وان يقوم فيها الامين العام
للامم المتحده نفسه بدور الوسيط
وشدد اوكرانيا على ضروره ان تواجه روسيا
محكمه جرائم الحرب قبل اي محادثات مباشره
محتمله معها في المقابله عبرت روسيا عن
رفضها التفاوض بشروط اوكرانيا وقالت الامم
المتحده ان امينها العام لا يتوسط في ازمه
الا بموافقه جميع اطرافها
الاستطلاعي ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
طرحنا عليكم السؤال الثاني ما فرص عقد قمه
سلام لوقف حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
قالوا ان فرص عقدها كبيره في حين راى 34%
ان التلك الفرص محدوده وقال اثنان وخمسون
في المئه انه لا فرصه لعقدها اطلاقا
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكن دخول الصفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
لقاءنا على المنصه الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
وذويه
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
خسائر اسوا عاصفه ثلجيه في امريكا منذ
عقود ترتفع الى 63 قتيلا
وولايه نيويورك هي الاكثر وتضررا
[موسيقى]
وقع الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتر
بتدابير خاصه على خلفيه فرض عدد من الدول
سقفا لاسعار النفط الروسي
وفقا للمرسوم يحضر توريد النفط ومنتجاته
من روسيا الى الدول
على توريد النفس ومنتجاته من روسيا حيز
التنفيذ اعتبار من اول فبراير المقبل ويضل
ساريا حتى الاول من يوليو المقبل واشار
المرسوم الى ان هذه التدابير تتخذوا بشان
ما وصفها الاجراءات غير الوديه والمخالفه
للقانون الدولي التي تتخذها الولايات
المتحده والدول الاجنبيه والمنظمات
الدوليه المرتبطه بها
هذا مكان قرار ومجموعه السبع والاتحاد
الاوروبي واستراليا فرض سقفا لاسعار النفط
الروسيه دخل حيز التنفيذ في الخامس من
ديسمبر الجاري
واتفقت الاطراف على ان لا يتجاوز سعره
برميل النفط الروسي المنقول بحرا 60
دولارا الاتفاق الغربي
واستونيه تطالب بسقف ساري اقل من 30 دولار
يذكر ان نفطر روسي يلبي قرابه عشره ونصف
المئه من الطلب العلمي وكان قرار وفرض سقف
لاسعار النفط الروسي واجهه تحضيرات من
ارتفاع حاد للاسعار العالميه
تكلفه انتاج النفط الروسيه تتراوح بين 17
الى 30 دولارا للبرميل الواحد وبدون فرد
سقف للاسعار كانت توقعات تشير الى ان
ارباح صادره والغاز الروسيه قد تصل الى
اكثر من
30020 مليار دولار
وقبل ايام كان الكساندر نوفاك نائب رئيس
الوزراء الروسي قال للتلفزيون الرسمي في
روسيا ان روسيا قد تقلص انتاجها من النفط
ما بين خمسه الى سبعه في المئه اوائل عام
2023 معنى الان من جنيف جوليان
في شؤون امن الطاقه في المجلس الاوروبي
للعلاقات الخارجيه
ومن موسكو
الخبير في شؤون النفط والغاز
وابدا مع ضيفي اذا اضيفي من
اوروبا ونبدا بخصوص سيد بوبو اذا كانت رد
الفعل هذا من روسيا متوقعا الى حد كبير
ما مدى جاهزيه الجانب الاوروبي واستعداده
لتداعيات هذه الخطوه
لكن في رايي هذا امر رمزي رد فعل رمزي
لتخفيض الاسعار الذي فرضته الاوروبيه
لاسباب عديده اولها
يتم التعامل او بيعه باسعار منخفضه
وهناك الكثير من الفراش
ليعدل السوق نفسه ونرى ذلك خلال ردت فعل
سعر البرنت الذي لم يتغير سريعا
اذا هو شيء لكنه لن يحدث اثرا كبيرا
الرئيس الروسي اختار ان يدخل هذا الاتفاق
حيز التنفيذ
في بدايه شهر فبراير او هذه الخطوه ان
تدخل حيز التنفيذ بمعنى وترك الباب مفتوحا
امام استثناءات يقرؤها هو ماذا نقرا في
هذا
فعلا متوقع
الجميع وتقدم الاعلان عنه من قبل بعد
تنفيذ
السقف
بالنسبه لنقله بالبحر
سقف السعر اعتقد
ان الامر يحتاج الى بعد الوقت
ليتاقلما
يصدرون النفط الروسي
وحتى نرى ان كان هناك اتفاقات بالاشاره
الى سقف السعر على النفط الروسي
والسوق يرد والسعر ارتفع بدايه من اليوم
بعد شهر واحد هناك من يقول ان الامور قد
تكون قد ارتحت بعض الشيء في اوروبا لان
ازمه البرد القارس تكون قد خفت بعض الشيء
هذا الشهر تحديدا ما الذي يغيره هنا
صناعه
متوازن بين العارضه والطلب
واذا راينا قيودا اخرى من الجانبين
فان الطلب لن يكون في مستوى
التزويد وهذا هذه
نظريه اقتصاديه بسيطه
والكل يعرف ما الذي سيحدث الاقتصاد الروسي
حقيقه لم يتضرر وهو بالعكس مخزون
الاحتياطا النقدي يزيد في روسيا ما الذي
يمكن فعله ان تفعله هذه الخطوه اصلا من
جانب الاتحاد وضع السقف والان الموقف كما
هو والاضرابات في اوروبا
والاستياء في اوروبا هو الاكبر والاكثر
وضوحا
نعم هناك تاثير لكن ليس بطريقه محاسمه لان
النفط الروسي يباع بي 5 هو ارخص ب 25 30
دولار من البراند
وهناك مخزون
ولكن السعر ليس عليه تاثير كبير لكن بشكل
عام
رفض
النفط الروسي من قبل العديد البلدان هو
اهم بشكل اكبر
برضو هناك الحظر والقيود المفروضه على
شركات التامين
والنقل نقل النفط ليس على النفط بحد ذاته
لان
معظم عمليات النقل تقوم بتتم
بناقلات المسجله في اليونان وفي قبرص
والان عليهما نجدوا اخرين
سابوي
التاثير ليس حاسما وكبيرا
سوق النفط العالميه فان زياده ليست الا
بواحد في المئه ويمكن القول انه ليس هناك
رد فعل حقيقي وقرار روسيا
منذ يومين او ثلاثه حتى لو تم اتخاذها
اليوم اذا نستطيع ان نقول انها لم تؤثر في
السوق
سيدكو هل كان يتوقع ان يكون هناك موقف
ربما اكثر حسما واكثر قسوه من الجانب
الروسي همم وخصوصا ان اا البعض اعتبره
الشيء ما فيه شيء من التراخي هل هو موجه
للدخل اكثر ام للخارج هنا
القرار
مع الحظر اذا هناك حظر وهناك سقف وهذا
موجلي السوق العالمي والقرار يتعلق
بالتصدير وليس لديه علاقه بالسوق المحليه
واودوا ان اؤكد مره اخرى ان انا سوف نرى
انعكاس ذلك على السوق العالميه بمرور
الوقت
وسوف نرى ان هناك سيكون اا نقصا او
انقطاعا في الامداد وذلك
ينعكسه على الاسعار اذا السوق العالميه
مرتبطه بسبب التحكيم في مجالات مختلفه
ونقص الامداد والتزويد كما قلت
سيكون له رد فعل اقتصادي على الاسعار تلك
هي الطريق الوحيده التي ارى فيها اتجاه
السوق شكرا لك من موسكو في كلاف مشينكو
وشكرا من جنيف لجوليا بوب الخبير في شؤون
امن الطاقه في المجلس الاوروبي
الجدل الحاد القائم بسبب تحديد سقفا
لاسعار النفط الروسيه هو وليد حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا التي دخلت شهرها الحادي عشر
وما زالت كيب وموسكو تتبادلان رسائله غير
مباشره بشان الجلوس على طاوله المفاوضات
وشروط ذلك في اخر المواقف تؤكد موسكو
استعدادها لمناقشه ما وصفتها بالقضايا
الاستراتيجيه الكبرى لكنها رهنت ذلك
بتغيير واشنطن نهجها اثناء ترد الامم
المتحده على مقترح اوكرانيا لعقد قمه
للسلام لاشترات موافقه جميع الاطراف
عام اخرون كهذا
تقترب حرب اوكرانيا من ذكراها الثانويه
الاولى
وذكرى يريدها الاوكرانيون ان تقترن بقمه
السلام يعرضون عقدها بواسطه الامميه
الى نهايه فبراير عندما تدخل الحرب عامها
الثاني او يتوقعوا ان تدخل عامها الثاني
من اهداف وصفه السلام هذه عدم السماح
لروسيا بالتلاعب بموضوع السلامه لانها
تقول باستمرار انها مستعده للمفاوضات وهذا
ليس حقيقيا
اي صيغه سلام ستطرحها بلادها ربما كانت
صيغه نقاط العاشر التي كشف عنها الرئيس في
نوفمبر الماضي ومنها استعاده الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وانسحاب القوات الروسيه واطلاق
سراح جميع السجناء ومحاكمه المسؤولين عن
الحرب
تؤمنكيه في كما تقول باهميه الفعل
دبلوماسي في انهاء كل الحروب لكنها تتواعد
في الوقت عينه بفعل كل ما وسعها للفوز
بالحرب في عام 2023
لذلك وغيره ربما لا يظهر الرؤوس كبيره
اهتمام بالمقترح الاوكراني بل رفضه
لا تتبع شروط الاخرين في التفاوض وان
مرجعيتها هي اهدافها الخاصه والمنطق
السليم هل يعني ذلك انا موسكو ترفض الحوار
من اساسه نقرا عكس ذلك تماما في تصريحات
كبار مسؤوليها بدءا بالرئيس نفسه قبل
يومين فقط
ان بلاده مستعده للتفاوض مع كل اطراف
الصراع الاوكراني بشان ما سماه حلولا
مقبوله للجميع لكن كيف هو الغرب كما اوضح
هم من يرفضون التفاوض
لاحقا اعتبر وزير الخارجيه سارجي لافروف
ان الغرب سيطر في نهايه المطاف للجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوضات اما بلاده فمستعده كما
قال لمناقشه ما وصفها بالقضايا
الاستراتيجيه الكبرى لكن بشرط ان تغير
واشنطن نهجها
للمتفاوضين اذن شروطهم التي جعلت الامم
المتحده ترهى نقابوله توسط بشان اوكرانيا
بموافقه
الاطرافكين بمبدا الحوار على اساس الامر
الواقع اي اعتبار المناطق التي سيطر عليها
في اوكرانيا منذ فبراير الماضي روسيه
على الجانب الاخر تطالب كيف بالانسحاب
الكامل للقوات الروسيه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه كشرط مسبق للتفاوض يبدو الامر
بالغه تعقيد ويبدو ان تبادل الرسائل
الرغبه في التفاوض لن يكفي وحداه لصناعه
السلام
المحلل السياسي من واشنطن معنى الدكتور
دانون انسان مدير روسيا والاستقرار
الاستراتيجي في معهد الولايات المتحده
للسلام
والتبلوماسيه السابقه اهلا وسهلا بكما
وابدا معك ضيفي من موسكو السيد
همم اذا كانت
تقول انها مستعده للتفاوض ولكن بشرط ان
تغير الاداره الامريكيه من نهجها ما
المقصود تحديدا ما التغذير الذي تريده
مواسقه تحديدا
يومين
موقفنا واضح وبسيط الروس
للدخول تريد المشاركه في مفاوضات حقيقيه
بهدف ملموس وهذا الهدف ينبغي ان يكون
واقعيا والهدف الواقعي
الاراضي الروسيه يتم قبولها كاراد روسيه
القرم
وزباروجيا وغيرها ثم
شقه
الاهداف اهداف السيد بوتينا التي اعلن
عنها في بدايه هذه العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه
ينبغي ان يتم تحقيقها اي نزع السلاح
ونريد ان نوجد
بلدا مستقرا هو اوكرانيا وفي الاراضي التي
ستظل اوكرانيه
ثم ينبغي ان يكون هناك نظام امنيا جديد في
اوروبا يشمل روسيا ايطاليا جميع العقوبات
ينبغي ان تتوقف وان يكون هناك حل وسط اذا
لم يتم الوصول الى هذا الوسط فان
لم تغير الدول مواقفها
وينبغي
هذه الشروط التفريضها والعوده والخروج من
الاراضي اذا لم تقبل من الولايات المتحده
تلك الشروط فان ناس سنستمر في عملياتنا
العسكريه
حتى نحقق النصر الكامل ثم سيكون هناك
محادثات جديده
لم تدخل هذه الحرب لم تدخل هذه الحرب
لتخسر والحديث الان هو عن ربما استعداد
لجوله جديده في الربيع همم فهل هذا الحديث
الان عن التفاوض مجرد ذر الرماد في العيون
حتى تقوى شوكه همم موسكو على الارض ثم
تتفاوض بشروطها همم بشكل مختلف
واو اه رشا
تريد المفاوض
انه لم يكن هناك مفاوضات لان الولايات
المتحده لم تكن تريد ان تقوم باي مفاوضات
واذكر بانه في بدايه في نهايه 2021 في
ديسمبر 2021 و يناير 2022 السيد بوتين
اقترحها او عرض حلا وسطا مركز المتحده
ورفضته الولايات المتحده ولم تتحدث عنه
حتى ثم لم يكن امام روسيا خلال اخر
يعني انت برده
عن سيادتها بعمليه عسكريه في اوكرانيا
وبتبعث حل نحن نريد حلا سلميا دبلوماسيا
لكن الحاله دبلوماسي يشمل
مخاويفنا
ومشاكلنا وافكارنا
وينبغي ان يشمل
وجود مستقبل امنا لدولتنا
ويوقف الوضع العدائي بين اوروبا و روسيا
ويقضي
لا يدمر ويقضي ولكن
يعيد ايجاد ويحل
اذا كان بلاك هوم
الثقب الاسود بين اوروبا وروسيا وهو
اوكرانيا وهو همم
وبين وبين اوروبا ايضا واذا كان هناك حلل
همم سلمي فنان يساوي نقله نحن لا لسنا
معتدين نحن نحاول ان ندافع عن سيادتنا
الرئيس
عاد من واشنطن وهو همم محمل بيكما كبير من
الدعم العسكري المالي السياسي همم بمعنى
ان الحرب على الاخر واقعيا ستطول على
الارض هذه الشروط والحديث عن مفاوضات في
هذه المرحله همم ما المقصود هل فعلا همم
ما يمكن القول انه اتفاق للسلام ممكن ان
يحدث قريبا قبل ان نشهد جوله اكثر قسوه
سيد دانا جونسون
على العموم اذا انتظر ان ينضم الينا السيد
جونسون ولكن ربما نفس السؤال استطيع ان
اوجه لك الحديث عن موجه جديده وجوله جديده
على الارض
هذه المساعدات التي حصل عليها ااه الرئيس
زينسكي في زيارته لموشنكن
والدعم الكبير
وثم مباشره يتم الحديث عن مفاوضات برايك
كيف نقرا الاثنين
السيد السيد
السلام بل من اجل المفاوضات
ان روسيا
نطاق في الشتاء او في الربيع
ويريد
المحادثات السلام في اسطنبول في الربيع
الماضي
وبعد ذلك
تراجع عن كل اتفاق تم قبوله في اسطنبول
اراد فقط ان يكسب بعض الوقت
اراد ان يكسب بعض الوقت وهذا هو السؤال
الجوهري ربما هنا لان المرحله الحاليه هي
التي تثير التساؤل خصوصا ان ليس هناك اي
طرف يريد ان يعني يخرج الا وقد حفظ ماء
وجهه والدكتور جانسن الان هو معنا من
واشنطن والحديث عن همم مطلب روسي بضروره
تغيير الاداره الامريكيه لنهجها هل هذا
مطلب واقعي هل يمكن ان تذعن واشنطن لهذا
النوع من الطلب خصوصا بعد ان زودت زيننسكي
كم كبير من المساعدات في زيارته الاخيره
اعتقد من المهم ان نركز ليس فقط على
مخيلات الكريم او على الدعايه الروسيه
بالمركز على ما هو الواقع وهذا الواقع
عندما يقول به روس ان ادائهم ضعيفه في
اراضي المعركه هم يتحدثون بشكل متزايد عن
المفاوضات الولايات المتحده اوضحت ان
الغرب سيستمر بدعم اوكرانيا من اجل ان
تدافع عن سيادتها ضد الغزو الروسي بالتالي
نحد سمعنا بلبل اخرى من الكرام لان خلال
الايام الماضيه وهي بدون اي معنى وهي
لاغراض الدعائيه من قبل اكرمنا من اجل
يحاولوا ان يهزوا من ثقه حلفاء اوكرانيا
هو انه
القواته اداءه القوات الكرام لان اداؤها
ضعيفهم يقومون باعاده موضع الكثير من
القوات وايضا يواجهون صعوبات وهناك انتصار
اوك تالين علينا ان نركز على ما يحدث فعلا
بمعنى انت يعني تقول سيد جنسا ان ااا ان
ااا بوتن في الواقع ويجد نفسه في وضع يحتم
عليه التفاوض لانه لم يكسب على الارض هل
هذا ما تقوله
نعم هذا صحيح هذا تماما ما عنه ان الروس
لم يغيروا موقفهم التفاوض من
فبراير وهو ان يقوم بتدمير الشعبي
الاوكراني وان يريد ازاحه النظام السياسي
هناك الحكومه الاوكرانيه همم بالتالي هم
يريد فقط شراء الوقت وكسب الوقت روسيا حق
قامت به حساب انها قد تريد ربما يعتقد
البعض انهم يريدون ينتهي همم لهجمه في
الربيع بالتالي هم يريدون فقط ان يكسبوا
الواقع سواء يتحدثون بالعوده الى طاوله
المفاوضات
لحد الان علينا ان نراقب ما يحصل خلال
الايام الاسابيع والاشهر القادمه على
الرغم من انني ارحب بحديث الطرفين مع بعض
لكن لا يجب ان تجرون العمل بعيدا على
العموم اشكرك همم
مدير جنس عفوا المدير شو او الاستقرار
استراتيجي في معهد الولايات المتحده
للسلام وشكرا جزيلا لجيفورغ ميروزيان
المحلل السياسي من موسكو
اذن حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا من بين
القضايا الكبرى التي بدات تشكل بوادر نظام
جديد بالنسبه لبعض الدول وخاصه المانيا
واليابان فما تاثير ذلك على مصالح
الولايات المتحده هذا ما نبحثه في فقره
المتابعه
اذا من جديد يتصاعد التوتر في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه خاصه في الضفه الغربيه اصيب
احد عشر فلسطين يعني على الاقل برصاصي
والاختناق بالغاز المسيء للدموع خلال
الاعتداء قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيليه على
تظاهره سلميه تمدد باحتجاز اسرائيل جثامين
شهداء فلسطينيه القدس
مراسلنا سمير ابو شماله رصد لنا جانبا من
تصدي قوات الاحتلال للمسيره
[موسيقى]
القدس المحتله حيث خرج جنود الاحتلال
الدوريات العسكريه وذلك لقمع المتظاهرين
والفلسطينيين بقنابل الصوت والقنابل الغاز
وايضا بالرصاص المعدني المغلف في المطار
هذه التظاهره التي انطلقت في العشرات الى
الفلسطينيين انطلقت من امام مخيم الامعري
للاجئين وسط مدينه رام الله وتوجهت الى
الحاجز العسكري وذلك للتمديد بجريمه
الاحتلال الاستمرار في الاستمراره باحتجاز
جفامين الشهداء الفلسطينيين في ثلاجات
الموتى وايضا فيما يعرف بمقابر الارقام
تقدمت هذه المسيره التي انطلقت من داخل
مدينه رام الله والده الاسير ناصر ابو
حميد وايضا عائلات الشهداء وايضا هناك
ممثلون عن المؤسسات الحقوقيه والقانونيه
الذين اكدوا من خلال هذه المسيره التي رفع
خلال نعش فارغ للتنديد بهذه الجريمه وهذه
السياسه التي ياخذون انها هي سياسه غير
اخلاقيه همم وايضا تخالف القانون الدولي
باحتجاز فيتامين الشهداء في سلطات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه المؤسسات الحقوقيه
تحدثت عن ان وسبعه عشر فلسطينيه او جثمانه
ما زالوا محتجازينا لدى سلطات خلال في
ثلاجات الموت منذ عام 2015 وايضا هناك
اكثر من 250 جثمانه الاخرين مدفنون فيما
يعرف بمقابر الارقام في داخل اسرائيل سمير
ابو شمالي الجزيره من حاجز قلنديا العسكري
الشماليه القدس المحتله
وفي القدس اصيب خمسه فلسطينيين بجروح
واعتقل سته اخرون خلال تصديهم لمحاولات
استيلاء مستوطنين على قطعه ارض في حي وادي
حلوه في بلده سلوان تعود ملكيه الارض
لبطريات الروم الارثوذكس وهي مؤجره لعائله
فلسطينيه والتي تفاجات اليوم باقتحام
المستوطنين وقوات الشرطه للارض وبدء العمل
على تسييجها واغلاق مداخلها
واضمن تغطيهنا لاهم الاحداث التي شهدها
العام الجاري نتوقف اليوم عند جريمه
اغتيال مراسله الجزيره شيرين ابو عاقله
وما اثرته من تنديد دوليا واسعا ودعوات
لتحقيق مستقل لكشف الحقيقه ومحاسبه
المسؤولين وقد مر الموقف الامريكي من
الجريمه بمحطات
تحولت من التمديد بالجريمه في البدايه دون
الاشاره الى الجاني ثم الدعوه للتحقيق
وصولا الى القول بان قتل شيرين لم يكن
متعمدا غير ان الخطوه اللافته كانت هي
ذهاب الجزيره لمقادات اسرائيل امام
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
[موسيقى]
اسطوره صحفيه قتلها خساره ماساويه واهانه
لحريه الاعلام بهذه الكلمات علق البيت
الابيض على اغتيال الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مراسله الجزيره شيرين ابو عاقله اتبعت
واشنطن تنديرها القويه هذا بدعوه لاجراء
ما وصفاته بتحقيق مستفيض لكشف حقيقه ما
جرى في مخيم جنين صبيحه الحادي عشر من
مايو ايار 2022
اذانه الجريمه وتحقيق شامل وشفاف عليهما
توالت واجمعت ردود الفعل الدوليه عربيا
وعالميا
بعد شهرين من الحادثه وتحريدا في يوليو
2022 اعلنت واشنطن انها طلعت على تحقيقين
منفصلين اجراهم الجيش الاسرائيلي والسلطه
الفلسطينيه وعليهما رجحت انه لا يوجد اي
سبب للاعتقاد بان مقتل شيرين كان متعمدا
بل هو نتيجه لما وصفتها بظروف ماساويه
خلال عمليه عسكريه راء الفلسطينيون الامر
انحيازا الامريكيا لاسرائيل ومحاوله
لتبرئتها من دمشرين محملين اسرائيل
المسؤوليه الكامله عن الجريمه وداع
الفلسطينيون الى تحقيق محايد ليؤكد
الحقيقه المؤكده لديهم ان شيرين قتلت بدم
بارد برصاصه جندي اسرائيلي غير ان الموقف
الامريكي شهد تحولا معاكسا حين كشفت وسائل
اعلام امريكيه انا مكتبه تحقيقات
الفيدرالي الاف بي اي فتحها تحقيقا في
مقتل شيرين ابو عاقله
اسباب كثيره قد تكون وراء التحول هذا فهو
ياتي بعد عده تحقيقات مستقله من جهات
دوليه منها الامم المتحده وصحف غربيه
مرموقه كوشنتن بوست ونور تايمز وبكاله
السوشالتريس خلصت جميعها الى تورط اسرائيل
في اغتيال شيرين ابو عاقله كما انه
استجابه لعشرات من النواب الديمقراطيين في
الكونجرس وقعوا عريضه تطالب مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي باجراء تحقيق مستقلا
في مقتل شيرين ابو عاقله التي تحمل
الجنسيه الامريكيه تتحرك الجزيره كي تقاضي
يا اسرائيل امام المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
مدفوعه بادله جديده تظهر ان شيرين
والزملاءها الصحفيين تعرضوا لاطلاق نار
المباشر من الاحتلال واللجوء للجنائيه
الدوليه خطوه رفضتها واشنطن واثارت غضبا
في تل ابيب
اسرائيل توعدت بانه لن يستجوب اي من
جنودها يقول رئيس الاسرائيليه المنتهيه
ولايه توحي ايرلابيد انه لا حق لاحد بان
يملي علينا اخلاق القتال امام المدعي
العام للجنائيه الدوليه توضع قضيه اغتيال
مراسله الجزيره شيرين ابو عاقله وفي ذلك
اختبارا للضمير الدولي الذي لم يتوقف عن
دعواته لتحقيق شفاف يحقق العدل ويكشف
القاتل ويحاسبه فهل يمكن محاكمه اسرائيل
بتهمه اغتيال شيرين ومن سيتحمل المسؤوليه
الجنائيه الجندي الذي اطلق الرصاصه اما
اعطاه الامر ام كلاهما وماذا عن جرائم
اسرائيل السابقه بحق الصحفيين تاريخ
اسرائيل الطويل والمثقل بحوادث الافلات من
العقاب من شانه ان يلقي الاجابه معلقه في
خانه التكهنات
ومن وين سايرسالون سامو رينو وكامبو
المدعي العام السابق للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه
بلا شك تتابع هذه القضيه قضيه اغتيال
شيرين ابو عاقله والمسار القانوني الذي
اتخذت
ما هو تعليقك على الطريقه التي تم التعامل
بها قانونيا حتى الان كمدعي عام سابق
القضيه خطيره للغايه قتل الصحفيه كانت
تكشف الجرائم هو امر خطير
العار هو ان فلسطين او مواقف ان فلسطين
نفسها ليس لديها سلطه
لتحري عن هذه الجرائم لانه حسب اتفاق
اوسلو بين اسرائيل وفلسطين فان الاتفالات
على ان القضاه في فلسطين ليس لديهم سلطه
لتحري عن هذه الجرائم بالتالي فان ضحايا
من فلسطينيين يحتاجون الى محاكم مختلفه
المشكله ان اسرائيل ترفضوا
تقوم بالتحقيق في هذه الحادثه اذا ما
الخيارات الاخرى انا افهم
اا بفعل ان الملف قد تم
تقديمه الى المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه
محكمه جنايات الدوليه وهذا خيار المشكله
هي ان القرار
لتحقيق تحقيق في هذه القضيه تحديدا لا يقع
بين يديه
الفلسطينيين او صاحب لكنهم قرار المدعي
العام بالاعتماد على قرار المدعي العام
اذا ما سيكون هناك تحقيق ام لا بالاضافه
الى ذلك فان القانون ياتي قال له
ان هذه الجريمه يجب ان تكون جزءا من سياسه
بمعنى ليس كافيا ان يكون
هنالك
ظرفيات حول هذه القضيه علينا ان نثبت ان
هذه الحادثه اتت نتيجه سياسه هذا ممكن لكن
الامر يعتمد بشكل كامل على مساله
المدعيه العامه لكريم خانه هو الذي سيقرر
اذا ما كان سيمضي قدما في هذه القضيه ام
لا والفلسطيني لا يمكنهم ان
ينقضوا هذا اعتقد هذه العام سابقا اذا
كانت هذه المعطيات التي امامك الان هل
كانت تقرر فتح تحقيق
كما تعرفين
هنالك تحقيق يجري في فلسطين المشكله هي ان
هذه احدى الجرائم التي يمكن التحقيق فيها
لان
احدى اهم الجرائم الاهم والاخطر في فلسطين
هي
تتضمن
وجود وجود الاحتلال في هذه الاراضي
وجريمه الاستيطان لان هذه جريمه خطره
يسيطر فيها المستوطنون على الاراضي
المحتله ايضا هنالك مزاعم ضد جنائيه ضد
حماس اذا بالتالي لدينا عده جرائم قد يتم
التحقيق فيها بالتالي فان مقتل الصحفيه هي
احدى القضايا المطروحه بامكان يحقق فيها
اعتقد ان احد
الخيارات هو
لان الصحفيه مثلا لانها كانت تحمل الجنسيه
الامريكيه بامكاننا ان بامكان عائله
الضحيه ان تقدم قضيه مدنيه في الولايات
المتحده وتستخدم السلطات الامريكيه
للتحقيق في هذه الجريمه وهذا الامر سيكون
ممكنا لقد ترفض اسرائيل الاعتراف بهذا
الطلب بامكاننا ان ربما ان ندفعه في
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه واجراءتها
بامكان ان يتم فتح جبهه اخرى وقضيه اخرى
في المحاكم الامريكيه ليست قضيه جنائيه
لكن قضيه مدنيه واعتقد ان هذا همم وهذا قد
اعتقد ان اسرائيل لا يجب عليها ان ترفض
التحقيق في هذه الجريمه اسرائيل هي فخوره
بتقديم نفسها على انها ديمقراطيه بالتالي
اسرائيل عليها ان تظهرا للعالم ان القانون
في اسرائيل احترام وان هذا القانون يحترم
يحترموا الفلسطينيه ويحمل الفلسطينيين
لايضا ابتسام
قضيه في المحكمه المدنيه او وهذا هذه نقطه
لافته عن العموم اشكرك لويس مارينا كامبول
المدعي العام السابق
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه كنت معنا من بنى
سارس
الى ملف اخر يتعلق باتهام الرئيس الصربيه
الكسندر فوتشيتش الغربه بالوقوف امام
البانيو كوسوفو همم معهم على حساب ارواح
الصلب المقيمين فيها جاء التصريح في وقت
رفعت فيه صربيا جاهزيتها العسكريه على
الحدود
في ظل الاستمرار احتجاجات يقوم بها الصرب
المقيمون في المناطق الشماليه لكوسوفي على
سياسات الحكومه التي تلوح بدورها
وتلوح بالتدخل لانهائي هذه الاحتجاجات
يصل وزير الدفاع الصربي ميلوسبو سيفيتش
الى قاعده عسكريه قريبه من الحدود مع كسوف
لقد وضعت صربيا جيشها في حاله تاهب قسوه
اذ الوضع مع الجاره الجنوبيه يزداد توتر
ما يجري في كسوف ان محتاجين صربا من
المقيمين الشماليه هذا الاقليم وهو موالنا
لصربيا يشدون احتجاجا منذ العاشر من الشهر
الجاري باقامه حواجز على الطرق الرئيسيه
لمدينه مترو فيتشا تنديدا باعتقال رجل
شرطه سابق من سرب كسوفو كما عبدت الحكومه
الى نشر المزيد من وحدات الشرطه الشماليه
البلاد قبيل انتخابات مبكبه كانت مقرره في
18 من ديسمبر الجاري في اربع بلديات قبل
ان يتقرر تاجيلها لاحقا بالنسبه للجراد
فان الوضع يستحق التاهب العسكري بل وتامر
رئيس الصبي الغرب بالتواطئ مع كسوفه
انتم جميعا تريدون الصراع تريدون قتل
الصرب ستكونون سعداء اذا قتل السرب ما
يهمكم هو تاكيد وحده اراضي ما تسمى بكوسبه
ولا يهمكم عدد الرؤوس السلبيه التي ستسقط
مدينه منقسمه عراقيه فبينما يشكل الالبان
اغلبيه سكانها وهم كذلك في عموم كسوف
بنسبه 92% يقيم فيها الاف من الصرب ايضا
عام
1999 وحتى بعد ان اعلنت استقلالها عام
2008 ما زالت صربيا تعدها جزءا من اراضيها
وتدعم الاقليه الصربيه فيها ففي الاجزاء
الشماليه من كسوفه يعيش نحو 50,000 سربي
ويرفضون الاعتراف بها دوله مستقله او
بحكومتها وينظرون الى بلغراد على انها
عاصمه لهم
تصاعد التوتر بين الجرارين منذ ان حاولت
حكومه بريشتينا عاصمه كوسوفو الزام الصرب
في اجزائها الشماليه باستبدال لوحات
السيارات القديمه من صربيا بلا لوحات من
اصدار محليه وبعد اعتقال شرطي سابقا من
صرب كسوفه ازداد الوضع واحتقانا فبدا
الصرب اقامه حواجز على الطرق ورفضوا
للصياعه لمطالبات حكومه كسوف بازالتها منذ
حرب عام 99 يتمركز في البلد حوالي 4000
جندي من قوه حفظ السلام يقودهم حلف شمال
الاطلسي لذلك طلبه بريشتينا من هذه القوات
التدخل لازاله الحواجز ولمحت الى انه لم
يحدث ذلك قد تتدخل بالقوه لازالتها وذاك
ما تعتبره صربيانيه لدى كسوفه لمهاجمه
المواطنين الصرب في اجزائها الشماليه
من فارس معنى ماركو بريلك خبير شؤون
البلقان في مجموعه الازمات الدوليه اهلا
وسهلا بك اذا تهامات الرئيس الصربي كانت
قويه للغرب واضحه جدا نقول انتم لا يهمكم
ابدا اييي حياه مصير كوسوفي كل ما يهمكم
ان تقف الى جانب البان كوسوفو ما تقييمك
لهذه الاتهامات
الدول الغربيه
كبيره على صربيا وكسر ذلك يقماني بحلل
بشكل نهائي الخلاف الذي يعود الى اكثر من
20 عاما
كلى الدين
بشكل كبير في شمال لكن التصريحات من
الطرفين بشكل اساسي موجهه الى المجتمع
الدولي الى الدول الغربيه التي تضغط
عليهما من اجل التفاوض بالتالي ليس هنالك
اي تهديد حقيقي
اللي مثلا غزوه صربيا لكوسفا مثلا ليس
هنالك تهديد لقيام كوسوفو باطلاق مثلا اي
هجمه عسكريه على الصرف الذين يعيشون في
المناطق الشماليه خلال طرفين يريدون ان
يتم يقدمها انفسهم على انهم هم هم من
يطلبون ان يتم تقليل الضغط عليهما من الذي
يتم الضغط عليه من الولايات المتحده
وفي كل مره تشتعل ولا نعرف الى اين وما
درجه هذا الاشتعال برايك هذه المره هل
سيتم احتواء الموقف كما حصل في السابق ام
انا الامر يختلف
الشعور مختلف هنالك ربما توتر اكبر
وعدم معرفه
لما سيحدث مقارنه بالاخر ازمه قبل 15 عاما
انا امل بالتاكيد انه سيتم احتواء الازمه
لكن بشكل اساسي هذا النضال بين صربيا
وكوسوفو حول علاقتهما وحول من الذي سيسيطر
على هذا الجزء من
الذي يسكنه الصلب بشكل اكبر هنا هذه
الاسئله مهمه وبالتاكيد من المحتمل ان
هناك الكثير من المسلحين ايضا في تلك
المنطقه الكثير من الاسلحه منتشره والكثير
من المجموعات المسلحه الشرطه والمجموعات
شبه مسلحه او المدنيين الذين ينتمون
انفسهم ضمن المجموعات المسلحه ليس من
الصعب ان ربما تاتي همم شعله قد تخلقه
قال في مجموعه الازمات الدوليه
والان الى الولايات المتحده حيث ارتفع عدد
ضحايا لعاصفه الثلجيه الى 63 قتيلا معظمهم
في منطقه بافلو في ولايه نيويورك وقد ادت
العاصفه لانقطاع التيار الكهربائي واحدثت
فوضى في حركه السفر خلال عطله عيد الميلاد
العاصفه الثلجيه التي تضرب الولايات
المتحده
من البحيرات الكبرى شمالا قرب كندا الى
اليو غراندي على الحدود مع المكسيك جنوبا
شله العاصفه الحركه تقريبا لم تتمكن فرق
الاسعاف من تلبيه النداءات استغاثه كثيره
لان الثلوج احتلت اغلب الطرق العشرات
توفوا بسبب هذه العاصفه اما في بيوتهم او
في سياراتهم التي غمرتها الثلوج او اثناء
محاولاتهم ازاحه الثلوج من امام بيوتهم
سجلت وفيات في اثني عشر ولايه منها
نيويورك وكلورادو ومشيجن ومن سوريا ونبراس
واكله هوما وبينما انخفضت الدراجات
الحراره الى ارقام قياسيه انقطع التيار
الكهربائي عن مئات الالاف من البيوت
الامريكيه في يوم السبت الماضي في اوجي
العاصفه بلغ عدد البيوت التي انقطع عنها
التيار نحو مليون و700,000 بين
بيتكم لا تسافرون فما يحدث ويهدد حياتكم
هذا نداء نداءات كثيره وجهها مسؤولون
امريكيون
لثاني الناس عن السفر لكن هذه العاصفه
الثلجيه تصادف اعياد الميلاد وهناك من
يغامر بالسفر للاحتفال مع اقاربها كثير
منهم علقوا في مطارات مثل بافال ودينفر
وديترويت الغيت اكثر من 15,000 رحله جويه
بسبب هذه العاصفه الثلجيه كان هذا حاله
كثير من الركاب الذين كانوا يؤمنون النفس
بقضاء اعياد الميلاد مع ذويهم
مدينه بفلو ثاني اكبر مدن ولايه نيويورك
من اكثر مناطق الولايات المتحده تضررا
بالعاصفه فالمدينه التي يقطنها نحو
275,000 سنه وجدت نفسها غارقه في الثلوج
وسجلت اكبر عدد من الضحايا اعلن الرئيس
الامريكي جو بارد حاله الطوارئ في نيويورك
بمساعدتها على مواجهتها هذه العاصفه
اعزازه ما يحدث هنا مناعه من يعتقدون ان
الاحتباس الحراري بسبب تدمير النظام
البيئي ليصبح تطرفه والعنف السمه الغالبه
على الظواهر الطبيعيه
[موسيقى]
دفعت الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وتهديدات
الصينيه لتايوان وتجارب كوريا الشماليه
اليابان والمانيا الى التخلص من قيود
الحرب العالميه الثانيه واعاده ضبط
سياستها العسكريه وفق المتغيرات الجديده
اليابان التي تواجه في محيطها الاسيوي
تحديين بيجن وبيوميان اعلنت هذا الشهر
عقيده عسكريه جديده تنص على مضاعفه
ميزانيه الدفاع خلال السنوات الخمس
المقبله والتزوج في صواريخ بعيده المدى
كما انضمت اليابان قبل عامين الى ما يعرف
بحلسا العسكري الذي يضم الهند واستراليا
والولايات المتحده لمواجهه منفوض الصين
المتزايد ضمن التوجه الجديد ايضا دخلت
اليابان في شراكه مع بريطانيا وايطاليا
لتطوير مقاتله النفاثه تستخدم الذكاء
الاصطناعي وهي المره الاولى التي تتعاون
فيها طوكيو مع دول اخرى غير الولايات
المتحده في مشروع للمعدات العسكريه اما
المانيا التي ترتبط مخاوفها اساسا بروسيا
بعد حربها على اوكرانيا فقد اسست صندوقا
خاصا بقيمه 100 مليار يورو لتحديث الجيش
ورفع حجم الانفاق العسكري بدءا من العام
المقبل اتخذت برلين خطوات عسكريه غير
مسبوقه منذ انتهاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه
لامداد اوكرانيا بالصواريخ والعتاد
وكذلك ابرمت صفقه مع واشنطن لشراء مقاتلات
متطوره من طراز خمسه 35
هذه التحولات كلها تتقاطع في اليابان
والمانيا مع توجهات الولايات المتحده
حلفتهم الاقوى والاقدم التي تعتبر وجود
حلفاء اقوى يخفف عنها العبء ويعزز رضع
الخصوم
لمناقشه هذه التغيرات معنا من واشنطن
ضيفنا الدكتور ديفيدني كبير الباحثين في
قضايا الامن القومي الامريكي ونائب مساعد
وزير الدفاع الامريكي لشؤون الامن القومي
والدفاع في اسيا في الواقع نحاول ان نفهم
حجم هذا التغيير في السياسه الدفاعيه
لالمانيا واليابان وتاثيره على مجريات ما
يجري في العالم حاليا عسكريا
لما يجرب
اليابان والمانيا وايضا للدولي المجاوره
لهما خلال العقدين الماضيين فان الصين قد
زادت من انفاقها العسكري ل 50 اضعاف
اليابان كانت بطيئه في الاستجابه لهذا
الامر والكثير من الاشخاص توقعه
اليابان انتظرت لمده طويله فان كان عليها
ان تحرزه كبيره في الانفاق العسكري لكنها
ايضا تغير العقيده الدفاعيه لكي تتمكن من
مهاجمه التهديد قبل ان يتم مهاجمه اليابان
هذا تغيير كبير في عقاب الدستور الحرب
العالميه الثانيه لسوء الحظ هذا الامر
الامنيه التي تعيش فيها اليابان بوجود
كوريا الشماليه والصين باستخدامه صواريخ
طويله المدى ادى منها ضربت همم ربما اثرت
على اليابان بالتالي اليابان لم يكن ماما
اي خيار سوى القيام بذلك خاصه بعد غزو
الروسي لاوكرانيا فان المانيا بين دول
اوروبيه اخرى ادركت انها فاقها الدفاعي
كان ضئيلا للغايه والنقطه الاخيره التي
ارغب باضافتها ان الولايات المتحده
متخليها افغانستان واعمال واجراءات الرئيس
السابق
ترام قد عزلت الدول الاخرى ذلك تلك الدول
حسب انها بحاجه الى ان تقطع خطوه لوحدها
من لانها لا يمكن ان تولي ثقه كامله
لحليفتي الولايات المتحده
هذه الخطوات التي اتخذت من اليابان
والمانيا فيما يتعلق في الصين مثلا تحديدا
هل نتوقع ان يكون هناك رد فعل صيني في
المواجهه
هم زادوا
الدفاع
وتتوقع انهم قد يكون هناك اعلان ميزانيه
جديده لا اعتقد انها هذا الامر سيتاثر بما
اقامت به اليابان الصين هي
عدوتها ربما الولايات المتحده وقد حدث في
زياده في الدفاع بالتالي قد نرى لما همم
رد فعل صيني لما ستقوم به الولايات
المتحده ربما الزياده في 10%
اطول واعمق اشكرك على العموم الدكتور
بتسدني كبيره الباحثين في قضايا الامن
القومي الامريكي نائب مساعد وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لشؤون الامن القومي والدفاع في
اسيا
شكرا على متابعه الحصاد في الله
[موسيقى]